I really appreciate it if you haven't
gotten a piece of pizza or something to
drink please do so now we're going to
start this is the inaugural speaker of
the 2011-2012 Saban prize environmental
venture speaker series my name is Stuart
EQ on the program director at the Yale
Center center for business in the
environment which runs the series over
the course of the year we're really
privileged today to have our first
speaker patrick von bargen who is for
those of you from the school management
is from the first class that ever
graduated from the school of management
in 1978 so has obviously an interesting
perspective on how this place has grown
and developed over the the course the
last you know few decades to preface
this talk I'm just going to talk briefly
about the Saban prize Saban prize is a
twenty-five-thousand-dollar
winner-take-all environmental venture
prize for a sustainable business this is
a competition that takes place over the
course of the year for any student or
faculty venture that focuses on
addressing a global challenge of
sustainability and we it's a sponsored
buddy andrew Saban Family Foundation and
administered by the Yale Center for
business and the environment this
program has gone on this is now its
fourth year all the three previous
ventures are still around in New Haven
going concerns and are quite successful
so if anyone has an idea or something
that they want to execute on this is
really a great opportunity for students
at Yale also backing that up we have
this fall on October 17th is the
submission date for the so vodka seed
stage grants so we're also offering five
$5,000 seed stage grants to student
ventures to to build up to be able to to
get to the point where you can compete
for that $25,000 so if you have an idea
that's at a very early stage and you
want to pull together a team and execute
on that this is the opportunity and that
is due on Monday October 17 17th the
proposal finally for entrepreneurs in
the room tonight the entrepreneurship
club is hosting a an ideation night
samee correct and you guys are going to
be doing that in Donaldson Commons and
that'll take place at 4pm so this is an
opportunity for everyone who's
interested who has an idea or is
interested in participating in an idea
to get together to talk about how they
can collaborate how they can
build the team and move forward to apply
to some of the sources of non dilute of
financing which we have at Yale which
really can help push your venture
forward today's talk just for everyone
is being recorded and webinar and that's
a through Yale University and then we'll
be able to put it up both on the cba
website and through the yale university
on itunes sec I'll get directly into the
talk now this is a really exciting I
think at the time period that we have to
and very timely the title of the talk as
many of you know is opening cylinders
box entrepreneurship and energy where
does energy innovation and deployment
policy gopher here and we're really
privileged to have somebody who can
speak about this from both the side of
an of an entrepreneur from venture
capitalist and from someone who really
knows the policy world back and forth
just a bit about Patrick he provides
strategic counsel to a wide variety he
works for director of Quinn Gillespie
associates and he provides a lot
strategic counsel a wide variety of the
entered their energy clients primarily
in the clean technology space including
solar wind recycling and biomass he also
represents startup firms using venture
capital develop clean energy technology
Patrick joined Quinn Gillespie in 2008
after having served in major public
policy rolls over 17 years in Washington
including chief of staff for senator
jeff Bingaman from 1987 to 1999 and
managing executive for policy and staff
for chairman William Donaldson of the
securities exchange commission from 2003
to 2005 he also headed the National
Commission on entrepreneurship and
served as the vice president for the
Council on competitiveness the only
national organization whose membership
is comprised exclusively of CEOs
university presidents and labor leaders
focused on American economic
competitiveness issues patrick also has
extensive expertise representing
start-up technology companies and
venture capital firms and served for
three years as a CEO of the center for
venture education Kaufman Fellows
Program in Silicon Valley the premier
education and networking Institute for
new junior senior venture capitalists
around the world patrick has his BA from
Stanford his JD from Stanford and of
course his MBA from Yale so please join
me in welcoming Patrick
Stewart I thank you for recounting my
qualifications but actually I think the
reason I was invited to be the first
speaker in this series goes a little
like this that steward and his committee
went out for pizza and beer one night
and they said well who should we invite
and the conversation got going and they
say well let's let's get someone from
Washington I mean it's such a
dysfunctional mess down in Washington
maybe there's someone who can explain it
and then after a few more pitchers of
beer they said well let's definitely get
someone from the energy world because
after all that's really emblematic I
think they could say that then during
the beer but emblematic of the real mess
in Washington because we haven't passed
an energy building for years the United
States is the only industrial country
that doesn't have an energy policy this
is really a sign of dysfunction maybe he
can explain that then after a few more
pitchers of beer they said wait a minute
let's really get someone who lives off
this dysfunction someone who gets paid
to live in this world let's get a
lobbyist so voila I am Here I am a
lobbyist in energy in Washington and I
sort of have a something to say I have a
scarlet L on my chest I'm the kind of
guy who you'll find in a basement of a
church somewhere with about 12 or the
guy sitting around in a circle and I
sort of introduced myself by admitting
my name is patrick von bargen and I'm a
lobbyist I'm really Stewart not that
down on myself although I sometimes
apologize too much for who I am and what
I do but poor sama Democrats so that
happens a lot
if you had a Republican speak he'd be
here making you apologize for who you
are especially since you're at Yale not
quite as bad as Mitt Romney's Harvard
faculty lounge which he's been railing
against but but bad enough so with with
that explanation for why you're
listening to me today let's let's talk a
little bit about the title of my talk
and and what this is all about so as
Stuart mentioned the title of the talk
is opening Solyndra's box energy and
entrepreneurship and where we go from
here I'm assume most of you know about
Solyndra and you probably know about
Pandora's box which so in those boxes a
play on but I am going to just sort of
briefly explain that because as Stuart
mentioned I was chief of staff to a u.s.
senator from New Mexico and we had one
very beloved governor and the state who
was a big rich Rancher from the middle
of the state and while he was governor
when he was pushed to do something by
legislators or by constituencies and he
didn't want to do it he'd say well that
could open a whole box of Pandora's and
and so I sometimes feel the need to
explain what happened with pandora boxx
myth in the myth the gods create this
beautiful woman named Pandora and as
they do that they give her a box and
they say this beautiful box that were
giving you you must promise never to
open well sure enough we know how this
ends her curiosity gets the better of
her and she opens the box and all of the
evils that plagued the world escape from
the box and we have war pestilence
hatred disease etc and then she quickly
tries to close the box but all of the
evils have now left the box
so when we think about opening cylinders
box which has occurred over the last
month what kind of evils have been
released from that opening in the form
of hearings and commentary on Capitol
Hill well those include you know
allegations of inappropriate White House
influence on decision makers within the
do II were they was it more than just
sort of speeding up the process what
about political contributor influences
that is we had investors in cylindrical
is there is there a connection there I
should note just on the side there that
you know it is impossible to find any
issue in Washington of any importance
where there isn't a contributor giving
to somebody about about that issue but
those those allegations hang out there
and then you have the evil of hypocrisy
which is pretty rampant in Washington
generally but in this case we have a we
have situation where many of the members
of the House of Representatives who are
railing against the giving of the loan
to Solyndra were also caught sending
letters to the Secretary of Energy
urging them to give loan guarantees the
companies that would build facilities in
their district and then of course the
another evil would be the excessive
risk-taking by bureaucrats in the
department of energy because they were
so bedazzled by the prospect of new
green jobs that they couldn't help
themselves and they made a bad decision
and then of course the perennial evil
that is alleged is that the government
is picking winners and losers so we have
all these evils unleashed by the
Solyndra controversy what is does this
mean that clean energy innovation is
dead as a matter of policy in the United
States I think the first thing we need
to do is sort of take a step back sort
of a sober step back here about what
this is all about
first of all let's talk about picking
winners and losers I don't know if all
of you have seen this report by Nancy
Pfund and Ben Healy of som where they
they basically looked at government
subsidies of emerging industry emerging
energy industries in the United States
and they they found for example that
nuclear energy received 3.3 billion
dollars of subsidy from the federal
government before I mean through their
first 15 years which represented about
1% of the entire federal budget oil and
gas received 1.8 billion dollars in
today's dollars or about half percent of
the federal budget for their first 15
years and for solar and wind alone for
their first 15 years they received zero
point four billion dollars in subsidies
or about 0.1 percent of the federal
budget so we we have a history of
subsidizing new energy technologies and
it looks like nuclear annoy alas of they
were much more favorite than renewables
are today and when you think about the
picking winners and losers argument in
fact there's the notion that one can
avoid picking winners and losers if you
are spending money making grants making
tax credits available making tax
deductions available picking winners and
losers is is inevitable sometimes you do
it on an industry level sometimes you do
it on a sector level and sometimes
you're forced as in grants and in loan
guarantees to do it on a company by
company level but the government has to
make choices under those scenarios and
of course there are inevitably winners
and losers what about the we were too
bedazzled by the prospect of green jobs
in the economy that we made this
judicious unju Decius investment in
insulin drew well there's there's
something there's some
to the notion that green jobs are are
worth pursuing if you if you look at the
solar industry the solar industry in the
United States now employs over a hundred
thousand people and that is double the
number of solar workers in the United
States then there were just two years
ago the industry grew by almost seventy
percent in the past year alone we had 86
billion dollars worth of solar systems
installed in the United States in the
past year so we're beginning to see in
the solar industry where we're cylinder
played that in fact we are achieving
significant economic growth indicators
that that are probably worth continuing
to encourage and then as part of this
sober step back I want to focus on a
report that was issued the same week
that the first cylinder hearing occurred
this report was put out by the American
energy innovation Council of the
Bipartisan Policy Center there really is
such a thing called the Bipartisan
Policy Center it's not an not an
oxymoron in this case and let me tell
you who is on this council so norm
Augustine formerly CEO of Lockheed
Martin Ursula burns who's the CEO of
Xerox John Doerr who is the leading
partner at kleiner perkins caufield &
byers one of the premier venture firms
in the country Bill Gates it doesn't
need an introduction charles holiday
chairman of Bank of America Jeff Immelt
of GE and Tim solso of cummins inc of
our part of this council and they
co-authored a report called catalyzing
American ingenuity the role of
government in energy innovation and
here's sort of what they write so this
is this is coming out the same week that
Solyndra is being hosted on Capitol Hill
and they say the time is now for even
more and smarter federal investment in
clean energy innovation and failure to
do so would almost certainly
lead to a lower quality of life for most
Americans they go on to recognize the
international competitive challenge in
the clean energy space that we they
believe the US needs to step up to and
they they say with China and other
trading competitors poised to build more
energy infrastructure in the next 15
years then the US has built in the last
100 our nation faces a significant
challenge in maintaining a place at the
forefront of a multi-trillion dollar
effort to transform the world's energy
systems and develop new high-value
industries that is a fairly significant
economic challenge and then when we look
at the sort of specifics let's say on
China alone China's production of solar
for export grew from 2004 to 2010 at a
compounded annual growth rate of a
hundred and fifty percent compounded
annual growth rate of one hundred and
fifty percent and then in in March of
this past year they issued their
five-year plan for 2011 to 2015 and they
the goals they said are doubling
installed wind capacity in China
quintuple eng installed solar capacity
and investing 1.5 trillion dollars in
New Energy new materials and clean
energy vehicles let's just take a moment
this is a bit of a savanna side but it
sort of focuses on that 1.5 trillion
dollars so focus on the number one point
five so while China is going to invest
1.5 trillion dollars in clean energy
innovation consider that last week the
US House of Representatives vote to cut
1.5 billion with a be out of the Clean
Energy vehicle program there is a
complete disconnect between China's view
of the clean energy market and American
policymakers or at least somewhat so
these prominent business leaders really
seeing the the potential for you
growth in the United States the
international economic challenge the
country faces they really step up and
say look no matter what controversy this
Solyndra matter has generated government
has a critical role to play in
supporting innovation and then they get
very specific about what that role
should be so they say first of all
private markets do not exist for certain
benefits such as providing for a strong
military improving public health and
protecting the environment private
sector is not driven to deliver those
public benefits and then they say the
private sector has tended systematically
to under invest in research and
development relative to the potential
benefits of research and development and
in line with those two recommendations
they those two observations they
recommend expanding our p.e which is the
agency in the Department of Energy
modeled after DARPA to fund breakthrough
technology developments in clean energy
and they also recommend making more of
the Department of Energy act like our PE
with structural reforms both in the
department and in the National
Laboratories so that deals primarily
with the research and development under
investment question and the delivering
of public goods that the private sector
is not driven to but they also focus on
a market failure that goes to the very
heart of the cylinder controversy the
loan guarantee program and
entrepreneurial energy companies and
I'll give you their general statement
and then in spin that out a little bit
for you so they say markets do not drive
innovation especially well for
investments that are lumpy high cost and
high risk particularly when the outcomes
of these investments play out over
decades in a context where energy prices
are volatile they then go on to discuss
the valley of death the valley of death
is sort of an industry term for the
following situation let's assume an
entrepreneurial energy company has has
gotten let's say an A maybe a be round
of venture capital financing they have
developed their technology to the point
that they can show that it works in a
product lab setting they may then have
gotten a C&D round to demonstrate that
that product can be manufactured or
produced at at a at a small scale but
one where they have figured out the
basic the basic mechanics of how do you
replicate that product for market they
probably have put together of customers
in the marketplace that they can they
can assert if we could produce enough of
these products and we sold them at this
price we would have these these
customers to buy then what happens so
the gun through let's say maybe four
rounds of venture capital now it is time
to bring the product the company to
commercial scale that means building
that first manufacturing plant that
first major production facility and it
turns out that in the energy field when
the the Commission talks about lumpy
high cost projects this is exactly the
kind of thing they're talking about
where you need a minimum hundred million
probably probably upwards up to five
hundred million dollars to build a plant
and scale up to actually be a
significant player in the marketplace
the question is where do you get the
money for doing that and unless and so
you the company comes to the the brink
of the valley of death can they get the
financing to make that leap to the
commercial scale and it turns out that
is incredibly problematic
banks well let's start with equity so
the so the private equity firms and the
venture capital firms they've been
funding this company up to this level
now they can't possibly and shouldn't
provide equity to cover the cost of this
this manufacturing facility banks on the
other hand are not willing to do it
because here they're faced with an
entrepreneurial company that has never
scaled up to a commercial level before
and there are risks involved with that
and therefore they may turn to the
company and say we're prepared to fund
certainly your third plant may be your
second but not your first and the
company thus faces the valley of death
and the question is is there any way
that we can we can leverage the debt
capital that's out there in a way that
they will fund that first commercial
facility and what what this commission
calls for is we need to develop a
first-of-a-kind technology commercial
and engine a financial entity that
addresses the valley of death problem
and it should have the following
characteristics they should say it
should have a degree of Independence it
should have private sector co-investment
strong public and private sector
expertise flexibility to offer financing
products based on market gaps and where
they're needed in order to really
facilitate this marketplace for
commercialization adequate government
and oversight self-funding a entity that
does not have to go back to Congress
every year and get an appropriation a
portfolio investment approach an
approach whereby it is assumed that some
of the loans loan guarantees made by
this entity will fail but that the money
lost in those ventures will be made up
by other investments in the portfolio so
that the portfolio itself is net
positive and transparency so that the
the entity is accountable
uh to to the public well they really do
a very nice job of identifying this this
key problem for entrepreneurial energy
companies and then they really set out
to define what this new entity should
look like and it turns out that the
Senate Energy Committee on a bipartisan
basis in a bill sponsored both by the
Chairman senator Bingaman and by the
ranking member senator Murkowski of
Alaska they have sent a bill to the
Senate for floor that creates the clean
energy deployment administration and it
is no accident that that bill meets all
of the design criteria that the council
specifies and in fact the council
strongly argues for its enactment so we
now have a bill that's been reported to
the Senate floor it is a very specific
well thought out well structured
approach to this valley of death problem
and could have a phenomenal impact in
leveraging private sector dollars to
address this need so instead of spending
1.5 trillion dollars directed by the
government of China we which we will
never do as a government structure what
it does is it provides the opportunity
to take our significant private capital
markets and put them to work in this
clean energy space so this is good news
right now the question is can we in fact
enact something like this and that gets
me to the second part of my talk which
is the political climate in Washington
okay and they are you know as a matter
of civics that we have a divided
government we that is we have a
Democratic president Democratic majority
in the Senate and a Republican majority
of the house
but it's also become a gridlocked
government and let me explain why the
house which as you know has rules such
that the majority can direct the timing
the agenda what bills come to the floor
which bills don't come to the floor and
which votes are taken can pass any bills
at wants pretty much without without
consulting the minority and so what the
house has done is that has passed
numerous bills including energy bills
mostly fossil fuel directed and sent
them to the Senate where they are
immediately dead on arrival because the
Democratic Senate disagrees profoundly
with the thrust of the bills so we have
the house pumping out bills that the
Senate will not consider on the Senate
side which has very different rules and
where the where we have as you know a
filibuster rule in effect that is
because of arcane Senate rules that
would go back hundreds of years
individual senators can block
consideration of bills by filibustering
them and the only way you break the
filibuster is that you get 60 senators
to vote to end debate on a bill this is
the problem we've got now the
Republicans have decided that they are
essentially filibustering every bill
that is proposed in the Senate so when
you look at the Senate record for the
last year we've we've really passed
almost nothing other than absolutely
must pass we need money for the
government kind of bills so let me give
you sort of a measure of this so as of
September 15 this Congress has enacted
into law 30 bills okay of those 30 bills
21 were naming public buildings
appointing members to the Smithsonian
board of governors extending a program
for 23 weeks until they can figure out
what the heck to do with it and that
leaves nine bills that have had any
substance to the nine have been mostly
funding bills like the like continuing
resolutions to keep us going until we
pass an appropriations bill an
appropriations bill the debt ceiling
bill those kinds of things and we've
actually only passed two substantive
bills into law one is an FAA
authorization bill this is just a
reauthorization of the Federal Aviation
Administration and we did pass a patent
reform bill that's it but let me give
you a little perspective on that so in
the last Congress when the minority also
filibustered bills by this time we had
passed 64 bills into law and then let's
compare with the 80th Congress in the
80th Congress by this time we had passed
242 laws public laws and the reason I
cite the 80th Congress is that was the
do-nothing Congress of 1947 and 48 that
Harry Truman ran against the 1948 so we
are essentially dead in our tracks I
mean nothing has happened we and so the
problem is not just this this gridlock
in the Congress we I think the problem
the political problem is worse than that
we we have a partisanship and
ideological divide that is gigantic in
fact I would argue that the two parties
now reside in two parallel universes
they have completely different views of
the role of government they have
completely different goals and they even
have different sets of facts and I
let's just sort of take those apart for
a second so the view of government
whether the the Republican view of
government right now is the government
is the problem government is the problem
so if that is your analysis of the
situation what you do is you try to cut
funding for it you try to strip it of
regulatory powers and you try to
essentially make new turret as an entity
because anything it does will cause
problems the democratic view is the
government is at least part of the
solution to problems and that what we
need to do is figure out what is the
proper government role but it's needs to
be a positive role to solve problems you
can see how big a difference that is and
I just like to point out historically
that that has not always been the case
so for example right now the the
Republicans have railed against cap and
trade as a cap and tax bill its
government regulation gone bonkers it's
got it we had to stop it well very few
people remember that cap and trade was a
Republican proposal a Republican idea in
in days long gone by the health care
bill that the Democrats passed in in the
last Congress of course was Romneycare
right for the nation and that was
essentially a Republican proposal so so
what what we have is we have we have
seen movement within the parties such
that they are now not talking about the
same role for government the same
problem that they're trying to solve so
what about their goals well what what
are the two parties do with their goals
well the the Republican goal right now
because government is a problem it's not
to govern successfully it is to win
electoral success so it is it is
absolutely true that that Mitch
McConnell who's the majority leader said
that his first priority policy and
political priority is to defeat Barack
Obama
and in 2012 that is his goal so and if
you think about it in that context when
you when you decide you're going to
filibuster every bill the reason you
you're doing that is to deny the
president that you're trying to defeat
any kind of credit for accomplishing
anything and moving moving the dial at
all on any of the issues that confront
the country the Democrats on the other
hand are you know trying to figure out
how how do they govern this thing how do
they how do they make a contribution to
sort of at least seeing government as
some legitimate contributor to the
solving of problems but again that
divide is is is gigantic and then the
different facts think it is it I can't
tell you of the countless examples of
where you know Republicans will assert
facts Democrats will search facts they
are night and day the opposite those are
amplified by a within the parallel
universe by media systems that just
repeat for the two sides what the what
the facts are and and that again if you
if you can't agree on what the facts are
you can't define what the problem is it
is very hard to see how you move forward
together to solve that problem there are
countless examples of this I mean if you
if you look at the speeches that the
President and Speaker Boehner made on
the economy it is like they are talking
about two different economies in two
different places of the world with with
completely different sets of problems
and and each will assert that their
their their facts are support them on
there um now you know I am NOT one of
those who who's going to stand up in
front of you and tell you a pox on both
your houses you're both to blame I just
don't believe that turns out you know
it's got to be true that one set of
facts are more right than the other set
of facts right there are facts and
there's evidence and we got science and
let's figure it out so don't
misunderstand me there well if we have
this kind of political environment which
I know I haven't painted a particularly
rosy picture how do we get anything done
and and let me talk specifically about
go back to this clean energy deployment
administration idea and energy in
particular so it turns out that the
house has passed a bunch of fossil fuel
bills and they're they're sort of
sitting at the Senate door in the Senate
bingham enamore Kowski as chairman and
ranking member the Energy Committee have
passed 14 bills out of their committee
including the CETA bill on bipartisan
books okay and why were they able to do
that because generally speaking that was
sort of under the political radar no one
was paying attention these bills are
generally not very sexy they're there
they have to do with energy efficiency
and hydropower and modular nuclear and a
bunch of other things and and it's just
hard to you know say that the freedom of
the Republic is going to be destroyed by
any of them so it's it's they've been
very much under the radar the question
now is can they go to the Senate floor
with a package of these bills and
convinced Senator Reid and Senator
McConnell that you know while we're
waiting around for the next big fight
here what if we what if we brought these
bills to the floor they're boring their
humdrum their their technical they'll
help improve the energy environment a
little bit you know and and and
basically try to keep it under the
political radar so that it doesn't
become the political football the
ideological playing ground for all of
these trends that I just just
highlighted and under that scenario
let's say so McConnell would agree not
to filibuster the bill okay that would
be the key thing if he decided not to
and they just they just sort of kept
this down as a
sort of a humdrum bill that they would
go to over a week or two period allow
amendments to see what happened then
they say the Senate would pass the bill
which it would pass the bill if it
wasn't filibustered because you know
they're a minimum of fifty three
Democratic votes and bunch of
Republicans would vote for two then you
would have passed the bill out of the
Senate that could be confused with the
house bills on fossil energy so the deal
would basically be look members of the
House and Republicans you want these
fossil fuel policies in place we can't
Democrat speaking we can't accept all of
them someone were just too far but we'll
accept some some pieces of it we'll go
with that if you take the bulk of what
we passed out of the Senate and the
value proposition for you is you get to
say you know we've been fighting for
energy independence through more
drilling and we've done that and we pass
this bill and this is a major
accomplishment for us and blah blah blah
and of course will do the same thing and
that's that's a workable deal in
Washington that that that's possible now
the I use the word possible and not
probable for a host of reasons first of
all keeping this under the political
radar and the Senate that is a tough
order someone is going to offer some
amendment that may elevate this thing to
the ideological battle field that's
probable will McConnell agree not to
filibuster died the problem there is
that that if the strategy is to deny the
president any accomplishments then
allowing an energy bill go through that
in fact might be conference with the
house that that then the president would
sign and he takes credit for an energy
bill maybe I want to stop that right now
so that that mate that reduces the
probability to and then of course you
have all the difficulties of actually
conferring with the house and getting
this all done so in this Congress it is
a
probably a slim prospect but not
entirely out of the question so as
Stewart told you Bingham is my former
boss he is a legislator above all I
think right now he is looking for what's
the right time to sort of pop the
question to McConnell and read make sure
the Macau skis on board and you know he
may find a window here where he thinks
he can go for it but and he probably
will go for it but when that window
appears is not not entirely clear
there's another reason why the CETA bill
in particular is hard one is that even
though we've assembled a very broad
coalition of investors venture
capitalists startup companies to Chamber
of Commerce which is a major Republican
organization think tanks that kind of
thing we're Sita is if it's eat it comes
to the light of day it will be opposed
by two groups it'll be deposed by the
the conservative think tanks within the
Republican parallel universe because
this is government doing anything in
this space and it will be opposed
ironically by most environmental groups
why because it is possible given the
scope the breadth of the scope of the
charge of Sita that they might provide
loans or loan guarantees to let's say
nuclear or other dirty energy sources by
the environmentalist counting so we're
in this particularly strange thing where
we r we have this entire political
gridlock problem to navigate and then we
have the right-wing think-tank think
that's that's understandable that that's
probably beatable but to have
environmentalists show up at the door
step of senators saying you shouldn't
vote for this thing is is a difficult
difficult thing so we're still we're
still working on that but it gives you a
sense of the challenge that that this
that we face here okay so where are we
in the future of clean energy innovation
well you know I'm going to go back to
the Pandora's box Smith turns out the
one thing didn't escape from Pandora's
box all the evils left but at the bottom
of the box was hope believe it or not
that's really in the mid some of the
retellings of the myth say that hope got
out too and we can you know we can all
jump for joy but but but I'm basically I
was telling some people this morning I
just can't get over my optimism i just
can't just won't so there's some hope
let me tell you how that hope my playa
so i've given you one possible not
probable but if it happened hopeful
scenario that this Congress would
actually pass an energy bill that
included some of these significant
provisions that would actually move
energy innovation but in the longer term
let's say it's not in this Congress
there are 22 forces at work that I I I
think are so powerful that at some point
and I don't know how soon they will
force the American government including
the Congress to come to terms and and
that is number one the the international
economic imperative of this huge global
market for clean energy that is going to
transform energy in the world in the
21st century then the notion that the
United States is just going to let
everybody else in the world play in that
we're not seems to be an unsustainable
proposition ultimately and the there
will be secondly the increasing
certainty of climate change
and that too notwithstanding the
Protestants of many in the House of
Representatives that that will become
increasingly more significant and
important and I think policymakers will
have to face it so that so that one day
instead of cutting clean energy
investments to pay for disasters well
actually invest in clean energy
investments to avoid disasters and with
that I'll take your questions hi thank
you for such an interesting talk my name
is Samuel I'm a first year som student
this idea that you've posited about kind
of a bank or entity to help support
lending is pretty interesting what's
your thought on why it needs to be held
within the government couldn't it be a
for-profit social enterprise or even a
Dacian that was supporting these loans
the the the proposal essentially would
initially fund the CETA would be
initially funded by an appropriation by
the government of ten billion dollars
okay and there would be an initial
appropriation and then that would be it
and then the entity would be allowed to
charge fees make money returns on
investment that kind of thing to
continue to fund its work from then on
out oh so if you're going to appropriate
any public dollars for such an entity it
has to be it has to be under the
accountability systems of the government
and what the proposal is is is is to
make this entity as independent as you
can make it so the the bill that is now
on the Senate floor provides for
a an entity that has its own board of
directors its own CEO appointed by the
president but confirmed by the Senate it
can hire financial professionals outside
of the government hiring system it can
pay them outside of the government pay
scales and the only connection it has to
the Department of Energy is that the
Secretary of Energy is mandated to
provide a technology strategy for Sita
and and actually the one good thing that
the energy department and its National
Laboratories can do is to think
seriously about what technologies are
likely to be the game changers in terms
of cost and effectiveness over in energy
over over the next 10 to 20 years so it
to me it's really an excellent
compromise between the the need to make
it as much a non-governmental agent
entity as you can but recognizing that
it still has to account for itself by
virtue of the federal funding that's
there does that answer that question the
government aspects but in the
environment that you described where
essentially it's probably dead on
arrival and not going to get anywhere it
seems like it could still be it could be
very successfully operated and privately
assuming you could get the technical
expertise and then that pool of equity
capital not to begin your to begin your
landing right and I would avoid all the
really hot so from you know that that's
that's an intriguing idea so from my
former boss's perspective he would be
thrilled if basically someone took his
bill made it a charter for a non-profit
and found ten billion dollars somewhere
that would be like ideal that I don't
mean to say that's not possible and he's
not he just knows that you know his job
is the legislature and he's he he might
be able to convince
convinced the Congress to take this ten
billion dollars and put it aside for
this and so he's going to try to do it
if someone can do it from a private
basis in a non-profit setting and
achieve the same results he'd be
absolutely thrilled and we all would be
Bill Gates is on the Commission he's
been quite step up to do that yeah but
cinder keep your cards and letters
coming to thank you for for your
comments my name is Raphael majority
queer student between hero and FES my
question is one of the concerns that you
know that people have about the Green
Bank is that you know of course you're
trying to lower the cost of financing to
stimulate some of these projects and but
we were truly really trying to do is to
sort of make up for the fact that we're
not pricing an externality that's you
know operationally there like you know
we don't have a price for carbon do you
think that that it'll really you know be
substantially helpful to try to do
through financing what we can do through
you know price and carbon and our
efforts better spent sort of pursuing
trying to can convince the American
people to put a price on carbon well
putting a price on carbon is it's
actually the from from a government
standpoint the cheapest and most
effective way to move the clean energy
economy in the United States it requires
no federal money and it and basically it
tells the private sector organize
yourselves around this this price and
make all the choices that you need to
make we should continue to urge the
American people to support that I don't
think it solves the problem that Sita is
designed to solve because even if you
have a price for carbon the the issue is
if you think about this entrepreneurial
company that is trying to get financing
for that first commercial plant
and you think about debt which is what
you need at least in our current debt
sector I think it is a legitimate thing
for debt providers to say look this
company has never done this before it
has never scaled up a plant okay and
there there are so many risks involved
with that I can't I would I can't price
my equity high enough to be I mean my
debt proved a high enough it becomes a
kind of equity play and i'm not i'm not
in the equity play business i mean i'm
in debt and and i think with
breakthrough technologies with new
entrepreneurial companies there there's
no way around that problem unless
someone steps in and says will reduce
the risk mr. debt provider of doing this
and this is how we're going to do it so
it's the green Sita is a very specific
thing from the Green Bank we actually
had two different proposals floating in
Congress when Congress one was a green
bank that really was more designed to
buy down the price of investment in
clean energy by down the interest rate
essentially Sita is not that much CD is
really focused on how do you get
breakthrough technologies to that first
commercial-scale plane and that problem
I think you need something like Sita to
do no matter what the pricing
environment you have out there I think
ya know the government the taxpayer
would be reduced absorbing the risk
right and that's why it's very explicit
that this is a portfolio strategy you
are allowed to make bad not bad
decisions but you're allowed to lose on
a few of the bets you take and you are
allowed to make investments on things
which are much more safe and much more
secure in order to ensure that you have
a you have a return that's going to make
up for that loss and of course that's
what most successful venture capital
firms do you know in the equity space is
you know I mean they they make ten
investments maybe one hits big two three
four are okay and the rest are losers
right and they make a lot of money
so for thinking about what what the
response is to environmental concerns of
iron moles concerns about what other
technologies see that would support what
what's the response what's the logic
that that comes to mind well part of it
is part of it as a political response
that is one of the reasons the CETA bill
is a bipartisan bill is that its
authority is broad across technologies
and that's particularly important in
this environment probably will be for
the foreseeable future but the other
answer is you see if in you you you have
to forgive me a little bit i'm sort of
fighting for this pretty hard every day
so I've got a few bruises here but so
the way I view these environmental
groups position is that it's much better
to have no money going to anybody than
to have some money go to people we don't
like that makes no sense to me you know
but that's the end result if you if you
oppose cita and you don't get it enacted
that means zero money will be going to
this valley of death for clean energy
entrepreneurial companies and zero money
will be going to nuclear and you will
feel good will feel pure we won't have
we won't have funded a nuclear plant we
didn't want to fund but we also got no
money to the clean energy economy
meanwhile China is investing 1.5
trillion dollars I mean I the fact of
the matter is that given the charter of
Sita most the great majority a huge
majority of the money is going to go to
very clean energy stuff some some small
portion of it may go to not our favorite
energy sources such that are like saying
there'll be a pie to split up versus no
pie but is there anything in terms of
what model
what we might expect what happened with
these investments so what would be white
investments Micah or what dollars might
go towards backing solutions that
environment saver versus those that they
don't favor modeling that's a really
good question it's you know that really
depends on the decisions that Sita would
make right and it's the other dilemma
you have you either in legislation you
either are very restrictive and say you
shall do this but you shall not do that
or you you give great flexibility to the
administrator with a set of goals and
objectives and you know that they're
going to be measured against but we're
going to let you decide what's
appropriate in a particular circumstance
when you do the latter you're always
subject to you know how do you model
that how do you what are they going to
do and and you know one of the one of
the other problems we face with people
say well you know what if you know what
if Perry is elected president and you
have seeped in place what will that what
will happen then I say well you know I
don't know point is don't elect Perry I
mean that's that's the answer i mean you
know trying to trying to design
legislation to be foolproof against the
political future of the country just
doesn't make any sense you what you do
is you you've got to set up an
institution give it some independence
give it its charter check in make sure
that it's doing what it's doing but you
know we have to take we as citizens have
to take a little risk that it's going to
be administered properly in accordance
with the intention of
of the founders and it is a risk we take
but but it's it's it's it's a risk well
worth taking and if we don't take it we
can be we can model exactly what will
happen which will be visible hi thank
you for your talk my name is Jen I'm a
fifth-year PhD student in the forestry
school and I have a slightly different
question than what's been asked before
so the cylinder case has already been
quite an arrow in the quiver of the
Republican candidates and the debate so
far how would you advise the Obama
campaign to counter that and what do you
expect their strategy to be on energy
policy within the 2012 campaign how's
the campaign with respect to cylinder
yep with respect to cylindrical sea in
general in the four years of the Obama
administration so far it's a very good
question so one of the one of the issues
in Washington this is Sir Washington the
question is so how long is this cylinder
thing play out you know how many more
hearings can they have what kind of
hooks they have is this going to be like
old news by November 15th you know and
so there's a big fight in Washington
about you know whether this is just this
is this we have a little sort of blow up
and there'll be a lot of scurrying and
then it'll die down so I think probably
you know the president right now and the
campaign see it's the president is to
his credit from my standpoint keeping
focused on a particular message right
now and he's not he's as you know when
he did his jobs speech and he did his
deficit of speech the word energy did
not pass his lips he's very focused on
those issues he should probably should
stay on that watch to see what does this
cylinder thing have legs beyond that at
some point he's going to have to
confront
you know so what are you doing about the
energy situation and you know i'm not
sure what what his answer is i mean he
can he can go you know he he hasn't
beyond cap and trade which he he was a
champion for waxman-markey he he hasn't
sent I mean he has energy proposals that
are significant so he can talk about
those and say they weren't enacted by
the Congress that kind of thing but it
looks as though when you when you when
you survey the issues the topics that
are of most interest to the American
people right now especially with gas
prices not quite going through the roof
anymore energy drops pretty low so I
suspect he won't address it in big terms
for at least a foreseeable future if if
we if this possible but in probable path
I identified plays out and we actually
pass a bill in the Senate I think he'll
he'll say okay let's let's get something
out of the you know let's get the house
and sent it together to confer and let's
get a bill but that'll give me
opportunity to do it but if that doesn't
happen I don't see his picking that up
on his own okay great
thank you to Patrick for being this
first speaker the save and environmental
venture prize speaker series our next
speaker will be on November third miles
Lassiter the founder of higher one here
in New Haven will be talking about the
venture and how he created once again a
big round of applause for Patrick thank
you